what's a full podcast what's up fool
welcome to another episode of the what's
a full podcast brought you here at
Achtung comedy studio in Burbank
California sorry my nose is a little
stuffy today I've been walking outside
without my with my with no socks these
are bad air making out with the staff at
all if it goes outside with no socks no
with my you know plantar fasciitis were
so foolish that's here Rodrigo is stuck
in traffic right now because of the rain
nobody knows how to drive here it was
driving off slow
they're either driving away to slower
way too fast
way too fast or way too slow what's up
fool shout out to people who are also
listening right now France for the high
schools Tony over ro the liar's club
still Steve wipe down Xbox illusion eyes
Tony over Rado Francisco's re said it
co-hosts over here here here right now
what soft pool
I saw started before slaughter shut up -
Martine Mourinho and debris they
actually been a slaughter band
yes well before slaughter I think oh
really
is the guitar I sort of the guitar I
don't know
answer my question who played guitar
fool Eric who played guitar for
slaughter but he just answers like that
no like there with sausage arms you know
like this
does he sing what does he do in the bed
no what's the [ __ ] guy yes he yah -
what's up bull Curt Allen all the way
from Florida is she
Martinez amid screaming but till the
lead screamer of the band coaching road
what's up fool acid cry shout out to ATL
still Steve he plays the maracas yeah
bro he puts up a ruckus is a big toe bro
it's our play-doh podcast we've invited
him to do the podcast and he said
alright alright yeah
how could I compete you know what eff
will has a junkyard dog you know the
next week I know I need on Joe Rogan
every week so whatever he goes were
people that do what they gotta do
shoutout to that Tobias homeboy don't
they stop bronson our guest isn't here
yet but we're waiting for jessiemae
yes leave a Peluso clear out my nose
we have a jessimae Peluso as our guest
to the end which is getting started and
thank you guys for listening and you
know whatever will be fine or an
appreciative if you guys cut it out
right or tweet about our podcast like
just tweet man one little tweak you know
class unity
I used to grab [ __ ] do
something hello how are you chatting
with the people cuz we're also waiting
on his co-host Rodrigo okay
what's up boo so our guest is here
little get ready I'm ready ready with
the one-two checker okay a scream what's
up fool
she's funny blood that's you I guess
okay what do you your more blonde than
me I'm not I'm like funny just of red at
this point in my life
where's the co-host of the year he he
must be shining now bro you know he's
driving a truck full of poison what's
shining he must be shined like literally
like bright or is that like a industry
term okay it's a word though there was
we're by weeded and Luiza 13 there's
something from Philadelphia there you
have some Philadelphia the rapper and
then he was pokey legs I get he was
smoking a good blood for the first time
I might have to take some of this to
back to Philly
I'll be over there chilling and fairly
shy I've had some blunts that made me
feel like I was shining I can feel that
yeah I like that that's a good word you
have an amazing skin oh yeah yeah you do
you're shining yeah I just bought a new
product are they paying you don't say
their name though you're influencing
somebody if you're talking on a public
platform
he's out there stabbing his chick I had
some blood that made me feel like Jack
Nicholson what happened briefly all your
lies and quit acting shiny the job
Redrum bro that movie's messed up the
Stanley Hotel you can stay there you
know in Colorado it was weird it talks a
lot about conspiracies but it's really
good but it's a lot of weird stuff like
like down to like triangles every what
you know like Illuminati sort of
conspiracies as well as what's the other
conspiracy oh the moon landing like
never happy on that it was faked and
Stanley Kubrick had something to do with
the filming of that what do you think oh
it's crazy if you're watching it like
the crazy person you might think okay
cuz there's a part you know where
because it meets a guy they hire him
yeah and that guy says that's telling
Kubrick said that's him beating John F
Kennedy and telling him about writing a
movie and it was gonna pay attention to
where the way he's sitting there are two
American flags and it here's part of
exactly John FK and now I'm gonna go
back and watch the shining cuz watch the
duck with the little boy a little boy
riding his a bike big wheel yeah yep if
you look at the floor or in his whatever
whatever he's wearing yes NASA yeah I
remember
yeah yeah and then there's all these
connections and even down to like this
there's no Sun Native American considers
this conspiracy : yeah
the aluminum baking powder yeah the
baking powder so it's like in the
storage room like the line how it's
perfectly lined up and like that's no
there are no accidents in any of the
shots basically is what they're saying
how do you mean restful taping that just
he's like just like a big stag stag stag
of luggage yes and then lately they're
making a reference to the Holocaust
it's very it's interesting now I need to
rewatch fool Rodrigo toys at the house
I'm living large and shining watch the
shiny brush I need somebody base you
know Jack Nicholson the shiny there room
211 or some I put other connections
together yeah what that we Turner's hero
of the election abduction a play site oh
how stupid us so stupid like how devoid
of love were all those people it's so
important to love your children like
that's where it all comes from this lady
he was doing everybody spoiler alert I
was over there like you hit the dad even
bloom right yeah a [ __ ] dad gave him
a handy in broad daylight stop kind of
watching this like who's that [ __ ]
honestly I know being a route a closed
room with a grown man no there's no
excuse and these even these people like
the whole Michael Jackson thing no one
needs to be in a shut room with the
doomed that's not I don't even feel like
Elvis bro
any of that dumb are you
well that dude they got right now bad
for Chi cago or Kelly yeah people who
are blinded by Fame and they think like
this guy could do no wrong or they think
oh they're just so enamored they're just
so overtaken by these or they're on that
payroll yeah that too they're bought
they like say hey we flew out here you
guys can go to Disneyland or whatever
we're just gonna hang out it's either
this or Wichita like can we just stop
interviewing our Kelly why are we still
interviewing him who gives a [ __ ] I
missed me I missed that
he did another enemy King and somebody
was talking about cried on it oh but
then they sent made it sound I haven't
watched it but they made it sound like
he stood up and was like screaming or
yelling
it wasn't confrontational it was I
believed I used to play the first time I
did a gay poor you know Paso right it
was yeah I'm hanging out at the
restaurant he goes amen
did you know open air in El Paso 250
bucks
[ __ ] you tell about gooood I've never
been anywhere yeah I cut a bus road trip
to a passel great the way they're red
there was some guy where everybody was
sleeping he will see you by himself it's
a good song party though it felt like
there like when I was young comic I
barely had like 25 minutes throws open
all of you oh I need a 10 so like it all
sitting there bad I was going over 10
minutes you know and chilling there my
my way to the bus what do you see that's
all I thought I would let the opener of
our boom
he was a lowly older I believe there was
a dude who just came out of prison in
the backseat laughter I believe I can
fly that out the bus trailer trash food
was just come on a prison bro he had a
[ __ ] cold sore of death man with a
dirtiest person he could fight God hi
and then he like he heard a back by
himself right he goes bad you said about
I have to fight you myself honestly
Buffalo you gonna [ __ ] you gonna fight
whether you're asleep right now
now way to go punch of right and then
there's a bunch of black people don't
like should I get a rally on but they're
all quiet bad but the way back I saw the
same four black dude that were sitting
next to one the inmate bro
uh-huh and they were totally bald man we
were to drop that due to a regular bus
or inmate transport we hope it sounds
like inmate right when you come what a
president they give you your money let
you earn what I presently give you a
greyhound ticket Wow because you have no
family to pick you up
that's messed up destination right about
that because at the Greyhound station
there's vultures like me buddy so I wait
for a mate to come out of that bus they
wait they wait for that to come out
peeled hey homie you wanna go get high
you were high and they have cash and
some of these guys go back to prison to
think that yeah that's why I'm after
lockup is the best show know it's Oprah
story I was like wait work owners her
nose was
we bill we esteem I own my own we trust
it might be under the umbrella I will
have a meeting with them you gotta look
that up because they where Oprah we're
part of Oprah's network after lockup is
oh do tell it sounds great it sucked up
with some with an inmate male or female
you know it's both sides male or female
hooking up with like a pen pal online
and thank you
apparently there are these dating sites
where you can go find some sexy pen pals
like a like tinder or whatever for
prisoners right not tinder but you're
having an online relation in there and
then you work up you know to a physical
meeting and a lot of them go to a
meeting so anyway this is basically the
show starts with the inmate about to get
released and they go into their past how
they how long they've been communicating
how visits that they've had in person
they do dating and all that dating
online some of the guys like one this
one guy on this one season he's old and
kind of nasty and but his lady is no no
he's he was not an inmate but his lady
was an inmate she was a drug addict in
prison and she fix her up she got him
for like ninety thousand dollars over
three years of course she did and she
had lots of tricks and she called him
tricks and she was like you know she got
about 800,000 from different guys over
the ten years she was in there yeah I
mean people that it goes back to people
being desperate for love yeah everyone's
looking for love in the wrong she comes
in a prison she rose up to him and
jumped on top of him and docks his 2000
yeah she's partial his little partial oh
oh this one guy Michael he has two
chicks he he has a woman that he was
with a baby mama before that he went to
prison she stood by his side poor she
did he married her in
present ceremony and like in his third
year of his prison term and then he was
about to get out but he proposed to
another girl online he's about to get
out with his wife now you know his wife
he married in prison and raised their
child together
she has no idea he has this other
fiancee this fiancée has no idea that
he's with this baby mama like a wife
woman thought they were safe getting a
better prison so this guy lied or a
parole officer was better wicked I agree
with the other girl yeah yeah and he was
late for his parole officer to meet his
parole officer and he got dinged and got
four more months
Wow he was late coming back you know I
would I would guess that more women
reach out to dudes in jail than the
other way yes I like well serial killer
skin love notes from women of homicide
in the world is from dudes women are
sending in those letters yeah again
that's like Fame their family you know
it's like I like a man who's good with
his hands
[Laughter]
[Music]
pull my hair
we have a friend named uh Marty Barretto
aka watch your back story we have one
apart you'll be the old friend of ours
and by either comedian also but he would
you're like you grew up right now I
don't know what kind of genre they have
every bicycle they had everything cholos
bar [ __ ] everything right but this guy
was long hear story yeah right so leave
to go to all the rock back other rock
concert but my friend made up a fake
rock bad
and you called himself slaughter but
they were played [ __ ] yeah
they have birds they would be they like
people at the party be like slaughter is
gonna be there like yeah and then the
members of slaughter are gonna be there
at this party a slaughter hat on
Instagram payback dinner
yo little blue so right now the weather
the fake bad slaughter is actually gonna
play they played on Friday right yeah so
everybody for the pocket one over there
they [ __ ] play like [ __ ] probably
slaughter before slaughter so Eric went
to see them how are they how were they
they really played I saw them it see a
regular run here yeah the 21st so they
really played recently yeah oh that is
hilarious
talk about a throwback movie about that
because now he's 52 different energy it
takes like a whole yeah you gotta have
that my cousin my cousin leaves to work
at a record printing place print
yes they were gonna play where they put
the stickers yeah
on the vinyl the binary vinyl record so
they have all the [ __ ] bro my cousin had
every [ __ ] album her house so whenever
I will go over there
it'll be like [ __ ] music plus for me
bro iced those I - before I - videos
beautiful yeah who was your favorite
band growing up the doors come on baby
[Laughter]
and then because I'm gonna have no rock
shirts but they two beauties chick they
used to live like four blocks down like
everybody in the house was beautiful man
except the parents the people who fly
people fly on others other daughters bro
you might be able to be a Tecate girl
the only answer to that somebody saying
you could be a Tecate goes oh yeah you
could have like a fake Instagram page we
just show you a ball licker 40s or
ladies
but I guarantee we win on our phones we
could find something very equivalent to
the 40 ounce shake that's my Mickey's
girl so what's up with those girls up
with the rock show
so those chase brother they was the most
about our hot boyfriend they took them
places or their whole [ __ ] sheep
we'll get to dry outside on the line
right we'll put up all their baby James
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah after or before a show
bo is like you know along the lines of I
never thought rods were funny broads
it's very like it's a very Italian
broads you know chickens
Roddy's coast thing - yeah East Coast
thing for sure but no chicks could be
funny just like too fast I saw Coco
bronze bro we get the [ __ ] bronze in
the gauge Syracuse New York funny bone
know I was a right there by Syracuse
right there was like the big ol
auditorium yeah we grub for sure we're
known for food and meth even like speeds
big out there - yeah yeah Rochester
[Music]
people came from yeah it was great I
flew out of Syracuse me and uh we did an
army base like two hours oh yes yep you
been there oh I used to drive by there
every summer cuz we used to spend our
summers unpleasant lake which is like 40
miles from there we go right by for
Trump is in middle of nowhere they got
nothing going on I don't even know if
they if they shoot off cannons or
anything fine there I don't know what
they're doing
there's McDonald's right there was a
McDonald's in a Walmart I remember like
like we left early and then the
Wonderlic RV guy was driving us back to
the Syracuse and I gonna make it we're
the only card road and was like 5:00 in
the morning 5:00 in the morning
they're like the guys talk eat it he's
telling for each other for days Mitchell
show a big tape when you're not driving
a vehicle whoever's driving is terrible
we put over to the side and then we see
one of those snowplows passing by and I
knew there was a Christ Christ who did
it bro who love to cook
was it the RAM Buffalo yeah we would
lose the coke What did he say you know
who did this to us
god oh yeah he's all blaming him we have
like what Jesus Christ always stay with
you're surprised you don't like whoa
[Laughter]
nothing I was raised Protestant my
family and I used to go to church until
I was like eight but then my parents
split up and then God was just like
family yo your family together I'm out
the doubt yeah we just stopped going and
I never adhered to any religion I mean I
believe in some I believe that there's a
spirituality amongst us maybe a you know
some sort of common conscious but I
don't know beyond that I don't know
they're bad like oh oh it is oh yeah I
put a video today I'll be rain even
their lives were on the blog in church
enough to get that ass I'll be starting
bootleg ashes today and I guess I'm a
[ __ ] from my weed hash Wednesday yeah
there you go
that's good I like that are you
religious were you raised hell yeah yeah
we were church too many times benefits a
community well I'm sorry but go ahead
we got nothing because we bounced around
from church to church so we're drinking
the blood of Christ no just like we
moved we moved a lot so we were in
different places and never really sat
down roots was your family in the
military no we were poor we would travel
wouldn't my dad was with us what his job
wow they're like fine construction work
around the country Wow seven thing I
[Music]
really and we were that's why we were
vegetarian but but that's what the way
she raised us at first and then we
started going to different churches and
we got older but we just bounced around
far as health wise goes for humans it's
a little it's a little Colton I mean
they're all little cultish but that's
what I was about to say like every time
I see the ashes on Ashwin's
I feel a little strange so it feels very
a little bit it's like I'm in a movie
with with people oh yeah the lonely Jew
[Laughter]
Park I'm a Jew yeah I mean I got I mean
religion I guess it's good if you you
know did they help you if it helps you
but once you start pushing it on people
that's like I write them I don't need
things to be this chick what's the
religion where they have to wear skirts
the women don't have to wear skirts
well apostolic people are minimize keep
themselves like she used to bring her
Bible into the lunch to the break room a
hmm I'm like [ __ ] we are folding socks
you think you're gonna bring some
salvation I am eating some busted ass
burrito cuz I'm broke as [ __ ] and you
bring in a Bible in here right now
I need Benjamins [ __ ] not a Bible yeah
you know just with a skirt on and
telling me I'm you know you need to
repent you're not living your life for
Jesus I'm lying [ __ ] I'll go out on
Friday so I'm talking they speak in
tongues which are not really speaking in
tongues the way the Bible meant that
speaking different religions
automatically they but they're talking
gibberish the feel the Lord brother it's
just a lot of that preys on people who
are weak and you know vulnerable and sad
and need some direction and then they
snatch money up like that van djegal but
yes angélica Jerry Falwell Jr Church
caps yes that's creepy
that's contending for power you
all the words get money I'm a big
Cadillac figure it out you really do who
was it joel osteen oh my god like a ten
million dollar house and Dallas didn't
let anybody didn't help anybody during
the flood like what's known as
megachurches yep
they're like super you're watching the
pastor on a Jumbotron in some case
that's like it's a concert you know
they're getting their dicks up okay I
don't get anyone says no one's in there
for the high of coming off I'm living in
the [ __ ] hovel that's a trip with
that [ __ ] but if you good stand-up
they're all they're all you know they're
just not funny your preacher colobus
he'll be on stage I don't know what the
hell he's stable everybody listening bro
like yeah yeah yeah it's energy you know
you buy the show like rallying the
troops you know it's just it's just how
you it's just control and you can do
that with any sort of device or medium
yeah same [ __ ] with mediums they're out
there they come out there like a dry on
a gym a jacket yeah I mean eventually
they're gonna get it yeah they go
through the whole [ __ ] alphabet they
go through every damn name Tim Tom Mary
Jo yeah uncle joe yeah joe do you like
pizza
yeah no full-figure he's a talent of
course who doesn't like me who does like
Pete yeah tacos thatha's showing up a
man feed have you ever had like a
psychic reading or anything by a medium
done we have Karen Montes key in here
she's a comic but she does like tarot
cards she read our car was very trippy
I like was it accurate like it there
were some accurate things that you know
and she wasn't like reading us she's
reading the card and see what that could
mean it could mean this or this and then
you kind of you know mind your thoughts
that's wild
yeah she was she's great she does
readings all the time I think she does
readings on Twitter before after hash
Wednesday do you provide like do you
provide a double service like you come
get hashed and then you read their
stretch marks that is hilarious you need
like a small storefront wait somebody's
there's a pre that doing drive-thru shut
the front door and lock it
call a baby that's some [ __ ] no is
he charging I he has to you know what's
funny I thought you know somebody has to
be broke do you do deliveries yeah bro I
got post me showing up bro but step it
up for me now did you pass by a Catholic
Church in over here in the morning now
pack was it it was packed there was a
line outside there's a lot of people I'd
say that should appear during the week
huh oh yeah Sunday's right now super
poppy did your father ever give up legs
yeah yeah he'll give up me for like 40
days or sometimes it'll give a drink and
stuff like that I always have a little
something that would give up what are
you gonna give up 40 days right yeah my
dad just gave up on four days
[Laughter]
my father will give [ __ ] and he'll be
sober for that the only time he has be
sober but I like getting closer to
Easter Sunday before [ __ ] up Easter for
us he was a nice [ __ ] up or he was
like mean [ __ ] up he [ __ ] up Easter
for us we can't find eggs we have to
find dad we can no longer other people
things they say Windsors where the drive
through Canada Oh in Canada yeah
charging give you your ashes a little
priest with dirty shoes in Canada huh I
wonder if he's charging if it's like if
he has a swipe can you imagine you swipe
for some drive-through ashes also
where's he getting those ashes how
sanitary are they they could be from his
Ash trainers cars
I wonder what where do they come from is
it for Mike's age or some palm
information as Wednesday connects with
Fat Tuesday like yesterday was right you
know it's all about balance and
balancing it you control people okay
you're gonna be okay this go get [ __ ]
up these parties like the purge it is
that's a good point like you you you set
up these parameters and people feel like
it's a part of a bigger picture so they
adhere to it and the more control and
like instructions you give a person
they're gonna follow more the world is
full of leader and followers that's it
there's no middle I know they would have
holiday for us for a reason bro yeah we
will get crazy yeah birthdays will be
sad oh no no more [ __ ] birthdays ever
again the more you see that [ __ ] song
they hang you
don't do good morning to you the
original song I love how there's like
different versions of the birthday song
like literally like most White House's
it's the most depressing song ever it's
just one Jessica Kirsten is a great bit
about that about the birthday song and
how different it is between like white
families black families and like
multicultural families because you
always you guys always do cha-cha-cha
you throw that what is it
happy birthday we put your head put your
head no sounds like The Sopranos holy
hell
do you really do that yeah shut up it's
tradition right yeah and then the kids
want to pick out their their cake
therefore the smashing like separate
from the big cake but they know they're
gonna get smashed Juan Carlos's
stepdaughter was asking for that like
she wanted to pick her smash can you do
this that was you the butter butter to
make a budget tortillas or no butter to
make a cake or butter to toast and make
eggs yeah
[Laughter]
did you strut count comedy and uh the
East Coast are out here I started an
East Coast I started in Boston for a few
years and then I wrote New York for
about ten I lived in Alston in Boston
and then I lived I did the broke girl
Circle in New York all around Manhattan
I was like Brooklyn Jersey Harlem I just
went around the island the BGC broke
girl circle yeah but I was in New York
about ten years I've been out here for
my five show you wanna first shows on
was in Boston it's place called the
cantab lounge they had underneath the
lounge up top they had this like little
dungeon room called the third rail and
they did comedy down there and I had
taken like a writing course for like six
months preparing which honestly when you
think about it if you're working on like
a late-night set yeah
it could take around that time to
tighten that up so yeah I did five
minutes I have it on tape your first
ever oh god it is it's like literally
watching your own car crash it's like
it's like watching just you die a slow
death it was okay but it's all hacky
[ __ ] you know it's brutal watching
yourself it is watch myself to keep
going that voice that like
overconfidence you have it when you
start you hear from people in no length
I remember I was the show called the
comedy shootout
bang comedy club comedy magic is caught
it was called oh the one that what's the
faith was talking about or you and
Deborah we're talking about
I mean lighthouse like people clap for
you in the middle
Wow demon ego give that you have that
like extra ego when you start in the
head you gotta think you're funny no
matter even if you suck you do the ones
who keep going have that I think was the
first credit it was true TV it was a
hidden camera show or like I was hired
to play it real so I had to like pretend
I was this woman who was getting
basically getting court order for like
having back like tickets owed I forget
what it was called but my my my segment
was called hold the Mayo because I ended
up rolling all my stuff at the guy out
the window yes yes real it was all fake
real to but it was too stupid cos they
put a big fat black dude out of a
two-story parking garage and will repo
Miami
it was different I forget what it was
called my segment called hold the Mayo
and I'm throwing all my food items at
the the dude that the officer and I
threw a whole tire atom in a traffic
cone I was like wow where's the limit
they're like just throw [ __ ] at him like
all right Wow it was yeah but I was so
proud the world's dumbest to him I
didn't do world's dumbest that after
that then I did Tyra Banks Show that was
like around the same time I was like the
same week actually I was guest on the
side like the funny chick and I was like
I actually did really well and then I
don't know why like I had two or three
appearances and then they're like all
right we're good
I don't know what it was I have no idea
yeah you know what I think she did say
that to me she did say that to me are
you friends with Tyra that's funny
because she will tell it to everybody
that was at that show and it would lose
yeah you know she got a breakdown about
one girl she was mad at her she said we
were pushing for you dramatic yeah she
was like I'm disappointed was sort of an
I'm disappointed in you sir I feel like
I had the same speech and in the green
room I remember how to interview these
couples it would be furries you know
furry like they have conventions yeah
yeah they dress up like characters like
Sonic the Hedgehog or just like a pig
and then they like they the whole whole
they always leave that part out they
both they both linka or dry-hump though
the guy was just starting to approach
one of those because you're worried
about sonic burgers yeah sonic burgers
you wearing no just a [ __ ] cookie
monster pants while you were working
there could be rave pants
Saturday shorts you know that's a fire
glow stick I mean people they're they're
you know they're whatever they like can
be kinky man people's fetishes I mean I
don't know if that's a fetish that seems
like maybe you got maybe you were just
babysat by your stuffed animals cuz your
parents weren't around again it goes
back to the lack weird as [ __ ] you mean
weird Len creepy can you imagine if your
girl was like you know I wanna I want
you to dress up like snuffleupagus and
[ __ ] me you know just call him have that
joke that I'm about the dude that I'm
his family and he goes okay he's crazy
but those other guy who cured a person
was a dude to dress up like a bunny
that's insane it makes you there's
layers to that that's a layered murder
right there don't dress up like the Grim
Reaper of the tiger batty podcast he
several Kevin Spacey in like the usual
suspects right yeah we weren't close
close but we spoke and I always love
talking to him whenever I saw him he was
always positive
the last week yeah the week before that
um he was super cool we met him here
like at the studios you know passing
then he did the what's a full podcast
but he's all super chill like I never
knew him until we come into the studio
he said yeah
she saw
warmups he said he knew everybody you
know before I knew Felipe when I was
married and everything we first moved to
LA I didn't have anything to do and I
signed up for a bunch of like audience
you could go to like the Comedy Central
was taping a bunch of shows over and
near where Estrella TV is now you know
over in Burbank and they were just
shooting one after the other so I went
and saw like three different tapings and
then I came back again Brody was the
warm-up guy two times he knew he would
he would do crowd work and a lot of the
people were locals and he'd ask where
they're high school where they went to
high school and he would know who their
coach was who their science teacher was
who and it was almost like he was doing
parlor tricks and then he would do
material in between there but I thought
it was funny and and just different so
different like you know weird and I
always liked weird comments not afraid
to be makes people uncomfortable you
know anyway whatever and he he walked
outside the line of where most comedians
danced with in he brought that like
cosmic [ __ ] to the craft I think he just
you know I mean he'd go out in the
audience most comedians want to think
twice about stepping off that stage he
most comedians only want the stage in
the mic Brody was like he lived outside
of that realm and I think he did comedy
comedians wish they could get away with
at least for me like that's the one
takeaway I just I he was an artist he
really was he he expanded every time
you're performing to a crowd of 200
people like if there were just two of
them yep yes because that will happen
bro when you work another room a lot of
bars a lot of shitty rules where there's
only five people there really will
[ __ ] work a full five until and I
will see Brody Stephens do even if the
crowd was like people say Oh easy crew -
easy crowd somehow that fool make it
difficult for himself
yeah keep out of a trap if you get it
kind of like the Brian Holtzman little
big brown hole in our McDonald's like
kind of weird yeah yeah if you get it
from the beginning you want to go in the
middle if you start from the beginning
of the [ __ ] show you know what we're
talking about
he's so so fun to watch Norma Donald is
he's like he's like it like a dessert
mm-hmm
for me he's just so unique I remember
one of the last times I saw Brody we
were doing a show at the dynasty
typewriter it was with Anthony Jesslyn
and the what dynasty typewriter it's a
cool spot opened up like I think about a
year ago James please yeah Jimmy flam
used to work in that improv in Hollywood
yep it's a cool theater you should check
it out bunch of old you the winner just
one and it was Cheetos Santino Anthony
Jeselnik myself and and Brody and he was
talking about that he was actually
talking about his anxiety with larger
crowds and how much he prefers a smaller
room in the dynasty typewriter you know
we probably had like a hundred some odd
people he was talking about his anxiety
with that and how much he loves to have
the small room and how that he feels
like it's just like you know a safer
space for him to perform the way he
wants to perform you know so that's
interesting that you say that because
that was one less conversations we had I
always thought that like I don't know
you when you perform on your Thursday
show if you have a Thursday show that
should because you're goof off so yes I
don't they - yeah it's [ __ ] fun it's
so those are my favorite shows it's so
funny and in those moments when you're
just [ __ ] around then you get the
tags then you get the extra lines then
you're like oh that's what should go
with that joke do you feel that like you
can sort of mold your jokes a little bit
back you know the too many that's funny
that was the only one some type of work
to Thursday's cause of only 45 people
there yeah
but I'm giving them a hundred yeah
I could show you make them think there's
but there's a thousand people here
I remember need to be a comedian a mom
for that it's [ __ ] day Frank Manzano
and he'll do a joke and then like he'll
be like he was right now you know right
now in another part of the earth there's
a crowd of 300 people and they're
laughing their ass off and I'm
responsible for it right now I throw
every back after a bad joke and then do
another bad joke and they hosted quiet
ago I'm getting an applause break on the
other side of the earth somehow he
stepped them into his world
yeah that's the key that is the key to
comedy right there is the moment you
step onstage you're bringing them in and
honestly like I feel I don't know about
you but when you step onstage I feel
like people decide in five seconds
either the crowds got it or you got it
from the walk from wherever to that
microphone that energy is so it's so
delicate and in bringing them into your
world is the key I've noticed that too
because I noticed that even like I was
doing it for that 20 years but sometimes
well now I don't had a go to the
audience it looks [ __ ] also said yeah
but in my head I'm thinking now
[ __ ] those were the first ones
open though that [ __ ] yeah and
trying to find your yeah your momentum
would you didn't find the right angle to
standing in the [ __ ] improv you're
digging your toes into your shoes like
settle into a new suit or new shoes
they're stiff they smell fresh you're
trying to like get your funk on it and
I'm so like people said I could go
anywhere yeah you go anywhere okay but
can you kill with a green ruler next to
the deejay
can you walk to at the Bellevue parlor
lives though you know when they open the
door and you hear the DJ and cuz it's
dark they started in the first show
that's right literally and then you're
like for the punch line and it's like
you know having a butt up as that he'll
open it to be a dick what I was working
at that was without [ __ ] what's the
name right that I'm comedian that a kind
of community we mentioned and named LP
so yeah that was hard
that was at the that was horrible that
was at the first comedy uh off the
cooter oh my god in that restaurant
there yeah
they move to a new place a permanent
place but you know that one word
beforehand I'll set up like those the
stage with right here and then there was
a boot like a big-ass [ __ ] speaker
though the greenroom
yep so I would just say no luckily is
that could cure anywhere but can you
kill after eating on top of the speaker
and there to have the energy yeah the
crowd of them see none of this no they
don't see it so can you kill when you
hear people shucking clams and for the
periphery you couldn't see love to be
taken out yeah I figured out the lobster
people studying in [ __ ] life some
dude Fellini young comic are you coming
know what to do are you doing dinner
thing go do five minutes okay
well you don't put up with five minutes
of hacky but [ __ ] about people standing
in line
Oh daddy like I'll have it there a third
pound lobster surf and turf whoa Rupert
get your seat sir you can see like the
whole kitchen
people don't try to be funny a group of
seven I mean just a little seafood humor
here folks
captain what was it right captain Bryant
dad always had the show watching the
show yes judging
making sure his buddy right yes
that place is so crazy I can't believe
that I totally forgot about them picking
up the lobsters and you seeing that from
stage and then be like yeah it was nice
it was nice don't you have people yes so
empty nothing worse nothing worse than
being a comic on the road in a nice
empty condo you're just like oh [ __ ]
okay this is why people just can't
handle it and join it all but once
outside and then like there's like four
other pools then I keep going there's a
beautiful beach actually people
vacationing families couples and we're
alone was with Domino's pizza sauce
stain on her shirt from the night before
not even the night before 2 a.m. yeah
big the guy he making jobs to go get
something you know just take you to the
Condor I'll just stay here and stare at
all the closets
I have done yeah I did the downtown one
and then there's another location is
another staple table close to the
airplane what time they had us an icebox
it was cold man you know you know it was
cold but you know Angela Johnson out
there the week before that because they
would had three heaters so they had
broke no no no heater it was freeze the
vent into that room wasn't on
yeah and so what you do freeze he
brought blankets for him is I ain't
gonna use that [ __ ] do you wanna give us
a ride anywhere I got a date today guys
with the very beautiful one though life
for you Bobby we can hear the lobster
screaming for their diet yeah that's
just it out that's their error to be
residential do I have what your ability
vegetables no I haven't haven't done any
late night before everyone else's Lopez
was he nice to you yeah that's good nice
to be your lover boy anyone maybe you
they got something wrong
just from what I know yeah they were dog
right I got weed in my pocket
yeah dog I've three what kind of like a
Steffi like a pitbull mix oh nice she's
head but she's very conscious lady but
she loves she does get a little excited
around little dogs in our rabbits like
she little dog she came up to she was
like she went in too fast for a smell
and that little dog I guess got scared
he just like latched on to her she
doesn't have any teeth but I mean she's
got the canines that come down but she
doesn't have a grab on they're all
broken and worn down from I think she
was in a cage or something for a long
time
biting and all the teeth are worn to
like the receipt through you could
terrible man people are cruel that's
enough that's creepy when people are
cruel to animals how can be cruel to
animals or children yeah I have three I
have three dogs they're all I've been
into a shelter three times I have three
dogs I cannot go into a shelter it's
just I'll come home with an animal I
don't care if it's a Capuchin or a llama
I'm taking that [ __ ] home yeah I'll do
cross country stuff like it you know
like I'm just gonna say Phoenix I'll
Drive them out there's fun you know just
me and my dogs chillin I feel safe I got
one pit Boxer mix and two little
ankle-biters they're all chilled oh my
dogs are all chill they're just because
they're like me well two rabbits how is
they having rabbits like do you let them
roam around I just picture them
everywhere we used to but they learn
these litter bugs yeah yeah so we would
just if they moved them around the house
we'd put a litter box in the other room
but usually they stay in the office they
have their own little space set up in
the corner so they won't go on the on
the floor they'll go to the little bit
little box house it take the litter box
train them it's pretty quick especially
if they're spayed and neutered yes look
easier I'm like I'm gonna get a [ __ ]
round but if they're not spayed and
neutered don't go a lot of places hard
to contain them but once they're spayed
or neutered all you have to do is like
like let's say they go in one corner
that they like to go into you'd like
clean it up with a paper towel and you
put that in the litter box or you pick
up some poos and that you find around
you put it in a little box and they know
oh that's where I go and they just do it
like that
[Music]
I need like a poster bunny she goes but
so both are rabbits though they used to
be oh you know free-range around the
house except if we left for a long time
what stopped that but having wish you
have that dog having the dog just
because we don't we don't want the month
supervised I don't know what can happen
you come home and it's like fatal
attraction
I wouldn't I would never leave them
alone because if who knows like one of
them would dart out of the scare you
know right in front of her face and
she'd get excited and jump but she
doesn't seem to have the urge but I know
you're smart you're responsible pet
owner she seems protective reach in
those backpack what you got in there
[Laughter]
I'm gonna be in Atlantic City at the
Hard Rock March 19th
the 21st and I'm doing lemon haze weed
festival the uncanny comedy fest at show
where Center in Kent Washington March
23rd yeah
and then some other dates I can't
remember I could never remember them
where's that kid Washington Kent
Washington like Seattle like near
Seattle yeah have you been have you
performed there besides parlour party
bar yeah it's so beautiful Seattle is a
beautiful place you did parlor in
Seattle before they closed it and then
you did it at Bellevue and then you did
the Moore theater last year right the
Richland - we eat in Richland what's
your favorite city or state to travel to
like your favorite place
yeah Portland's dope yeah great food
more than one day there yeah I know yeah
but you know then it's like the thought
of like cuz you travel for work the
thought of extending it you're like I
just want my bed yeah you know what I
mean you're like but it is kind of cool
like that's one of the upsides of doing
this like you get to see the country in
the world essentially you know depending
on where it takes you but it's a good
stop like even when I was working there
at Harveys catching the bus - back and
forth through the show I was okay with
that man and then a date-time I was just
gonna eat real good food yeah
or the bookstore get out [ __ ] store
that [ __ ] what do you do like what are
your favorite things to do when you get
into a city well he like went to museums
and I'm stopping them purse-snatchers in
bridgeberg
oh just by chance Bridgeport Connecticut
two big-ass dudes trying to run after
him and then there was a meter maid on
the other side how long these dudes
gonna run for how fast that's when you
see something like alright I gotta do
something she was uh she was on the
phone with somebody because her
husband's in the in the hospital Munich
ate with him so I thought about a
prescription stuff so she know how to
livelihood in her little device as we
all do yeah people are I mean people are
desperate I remember seeing a chick on
her phone on the subway in New York just
texting this kid just swooped and got
right off waited for the doors to just
about closed and God she was just like
so rookie move right there sitting
brother already like a friend of my head
is chased Nash in the bus you're sitting
by the exit fake chain boy snapped you
jumped off that's [ __ ] up with you
know it's a good game hunters out there
survival of the fittest when you don't
get your basic rights people get
desperate they'll come at you man Jesse
I've been half man I just need your name
on it
all right I got I got this movie man
GG mirror's say he might do it my god
Bray Wyatt back for sure righty but if
you do it always I just got one yeah we
are like how much W finally she reads it
so I would have to be like getting
trouble later on is smart I need one of
these I need a smart woman in my corner
I have too many dudes capable but I need
a little estrogen in my corner I will do
the lazy butt like you understand like
how to separate and work for our
emotions really I feel people would say
that about women yeah I don't know I've
cried at work before not not this
emotionally involved with somebody thank
you
yeah but I think that's the nature of
the business especially because with
comedians were sensitive as much as
we're egotistical I call us insecure
narcissists where we Teeter on both
sides of that so it's an emotional thing
I get emotional with my people and I get
told oh I'm just a woman it's like it
but isn't there also an artist factor
involved here can I just also just be a
human you [ __ ] you know what I mean
like it's just I feel like you can be
sensitive I'm sure you're sensitive
[Music]
no yeah I know I think I think that what
she's saying is true yet that you are
insecure narcissists all of you guys all
of it some of you guys are more but I'm
a Gemini right do not know what you're
saying okay just uses that as an excuse
to show us crazy the dual the Jekyll and
Hyde yeah you guys believe in all the
science and all
but if you think of it we're born from
the cosmos right you know between right
and wrong
yeah I have one called the hilarious
podcast
you gotta come you have to come
hilarious we smoked a specific strain
and then we tackle a topic okay yeah
like parenting or you know being a
comedian or whatever whatever your thing
is I know what you know I think there's
been too much crossbreeding what I see
yeah better than everything a hybrid now
I loo easy Oh G it's down to the strain
not so much the indica and sativa
because there's been so much
crossbreeding like in the 60s when the
plants first were being bred then you
could have a more isolated strain and a
more isolated dominating into car sativa
property but that was male/female stress
right Reggie yeah babies yeah Louise
stuff he's kept it it's almost like
heirloom tomatoes oh gee and he has his
own grower who's dedicated to him and
they don't he doesn't have another
strain or anything right he doesn't have
a crossbreed guy it's just his thing
yeah there's I think there's definitely
people who could still maintain they
even brought that plant to Los Angeles
yeah
but I think the stickier because growing
indoors
yeah yeah mr. Kiki I love I love
marijuana I enjoy it I but I go by like
I'll go by the the company in their
strain you know I don't go by indica or
sativa or hybrid or anything like that I
just go by this specific strain we got
back one of these over here I told you
one of the cigarette stands over on
Devin sure in the valley they have
banana I haven't tried in a flavored see
what some food this week I'm at the
Miami improv March 8th through the 10th
at the brand-new improv Stan Angelou
March 15 Wichita March 16 Grand Junction
Colorado
March 23rd Dallas Texas at the Arlington
improv March 29th through 31st check out
Philippe in WorldCom slash tour for our
upcoming shows and ticket info also I'm
doing a Spanish show on what day March
18th March Francisco Ramos that's gonna
be great it's a great show always this
Thompson girls speak Spanish very well
bricio Capano as well see we don't see
with the Oilers are in now thank you
still sees cuckoo cuckoo I think I need
the CBD stuff that's heavier on the CBD
than the THC when it when it's something
I ingest because I can handle edibles I
need something that gives me the calm
without the super crazy I can't take it
or you rub it on you I do have a lotion
that I think
wolfy gave us it works we have a little
problem in my hand here a joint joint
problem
but I broke tit on and it was
immediately another product CBD is it
that's literally going to affect the
pharmaceutical industry yeah but and I
do have some drops that are mostly CBD
and like it's two to one I think
something like that that's my ratio so
but do you it's I haven't really noticed
a strong although I'm kind of increasing
the number of jobs that I put in but I
haven't noticed a strong calming
sensation yet I don't know okay I guess
it kind of takes the edge off a little
bit you take the edge off a little and I
feel like sometimes there's no high
really yes not because the CBD the way
like that all of that interacts with
your end okay Nana book canna Boyd
system is like it's all dependent upon
where you're at yeah in your mind I
think I hurt my knee [ __ ] walking CBD
[ __ ] walk cream yes I my stuff is really
good
April ninth V villas jokes is back at
Riverside downtown Riverside at the life
of anybody was so well let's just do
that one that's what a Riverside we want
to do it the following month or that way
to tell what Tuesday night are they
explaining April 9th are they expected
to be in English no no we're bringing it
back but if you want to do that April 9
V bellows jokes and we'll be in Spanish
in Riverside California at the lifeboat
you'll be looking downtown Riverside so
come out folks it's gonna be awesome if
you know anybody out there that could
tell a funny joke is bad and bring him
Bob well put him on stage let's do it
fire coming to make it in abuela way low
ya know transgender a boy park at again
they can find me at jessiemae Peluso on
all things sharp tongue pop I'm not a
paid regular syllables me there all the
time I'm on all the shows so I just
consider myself crazy I see your name on
the list
really oh yeah I mean I'm there all the
time I'm just not a paid yeah I just
can't park my car in the watch Oh
[Laughter]
understand that the The Improv I still
like the way you used to be bro why just
martyr yeah that's all agree which one
really know where to hide it in a war
yeah man you get [ __ ] drug or high and
good and you like sometimes like I like
to go with the for the main room is
whatever the cashier is you could go
upstairs and you can like start looking
around where they cut off access for the
book yes well I find a little spot and
there there little nooks that's weird
cuz I was there by the oh are when you
cross the bathroom and then you look to
the main room there's another room you
cross and there's like a little window
you could just see the show but not hear
it that's weird it's like a cop window
[Laughter]
[Music]
help my son with his homework that's a
show yeah that's important
oh yeah I'm running your company too oh
yeah she's your sets together because
they're gonna film or your third special
you know this year our third special
pretty much she's your centrifugal force
so we guy hear that there's two [ __ ]
Captain Marvel always coming out there
are yes oh the one that's out now brie
Larson from Marvel marvelous mrs. Mazal
really bad a doctor that she dates
Jewish doctor she meets in the Catskills
he's going to be Shazam but with a
little boy who met somebody way back
like oh just see my name's you see my
name somebody heckling me in the way
stuff is stupid it is back in white with
drives or Beetlejuice brahms [ __ ]
chillin bro and join the [ __ ] rain
raining cats and dogs out this
[ __ ] and I'm saying Joe Rogan
and that is Joe's bro
well you know what they're talking about
the new sell our University well Joe I'm
gonna tell you one thing I don't even
know what's going on here did those
children kill those people
bro [ __ ] both you [ __ ] I'm out
worse
[Laughter]